[Music]
on this wednesday night
health canada's stamp of approval for a
second covid19 vaccine
how soon it'll get here and why
canadians still can't let their guard
down
you can be part of the solution avoiding
a christmas
home alone bit of a risk even though it
you know
it's following the rule the praise and
criticism to alberta's restriction
revision what happened inside this
prison
the correctional officers accused in an
indigenous inmate's death
and dear michael and michael it doesn't
matter if they ever see the card
they hear that the cards are there the
campaign to brighten christmas for two
canadians detained
in china
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with good news
about the fight against coven 19. health
canada has given the green light to a
second
vaccine the federal agency says its
review found the moderna vaccine to be
both safe and effective
according to moderna the first doses
could arrive in canada by christmas day
up to 168 000 doses are expected to be
delivered
by the end of next week unlike the
pfizer biontech vaccine
the modernist shot doesn't require ultra
cold freezers so
it'll be easier to ship to northern
remote and indigenous communities
this authorization is a critical step in
ensuring a covid19 vaccine is available
to all canadians
in all parts of the country if all goes
according to plan
the first modernity doses will arrive in
the territories by december 28th
rollout will then ramp up in the new
year in tonight's top story we look at
canada's vaccination operation
and the warnings as we head into
christmas break here's michael couture
the first doses of our guaranteed 40
million dose order from moderna
will arrive in the coming days prime
minister justin trudeau's tidings of joy
didn't stop there in addition to the
first shipments of the modern vaccine
canada is getting an extra quarter of a
million pfizer buy-in tech doses
in january we're on track to have at
least 1.2
million doses from both pfizer and
moderna
delivered by january 31st it means
600 000 canadians could be immunized by
the end of the first month
of next year health officials say
they're still on track to inoculate
everyone who wants a covid19 vaccine
by the end of september 2021. one
key to herd immunity for canada is
making sure the vaccine gets to everyone
something officials can finally start in
remote areas like the territories
because the moderna vaccine travels
better than pfizer's
the planning a sort of uh assumption has
been to really
deliver enough vaccine to be able to
cover 75 percent of their population so
that we're not making multiple trips to
a small community
other vaccines from astrazeneca and
johnson johnson
are being reviewed by health canada in
both of those the reviews are
progressing and they're progressing well
but in both cases we're still waiting
for packages of information
even without those two canada is still
on track to have
6 million doses of vaccines by the end
of march
we're almost there but we're not there
yet
covet 19 cases continue to climb in
canada even
as ontario and quebec prepare for
lockdowns
the prime minister is urging canadians
to resist the temptation to bend the
rules
and gather over the holidays reach out
over zoom reach out
over the phone to make sure that people
know we're thinking of them
and part of our love for them and
thinking of them is
not showing up to give them a hug this
christmas
with the hope that things will be much
closer to normal
next christmas michael couture global
news ottawa
the plea for canadians to stay home for
the holidays is being repeated across
the country
especially in the two biggest provinces
where infection numbers are surging
for the second day in a row quebec
shattered its record for daily new cases
with more than
2 200 infections 74 more people died
in ontario there were more than 2 400
new infections
that's the second highest case count in
the province since the start of the
pandemic
41 more people died in toronto there
were more than 600 new cases today the
city's top doctor says she understands
how
hard it is for people but she's
reminding them that there
is light at the end of the tunnel it is
natural
to want to rebel in some way against all
the obstacles
we face but this
is just one year of the unusual
and next year i believe that we can
expect better things
alberta has eased its restrictions on
holiday gatherings just in time for
christmas
beginning today and for the next five
days single people can join another
household for a get-together
but the number of kova 19
hospitalizations continues to climb to
record numbers
and as heather york's west explains what
people do over the holidays will have a
huge impact on the health system
in the new year for brian letts it's
been an
unexpected christmas surprise i
instantly took a screenshot
and sent it to my boyfriend
um yeah like
excited you know because i'm able to
actually have
a christmas i guess we've made some
changes to the public health
restrictions that will allow
single albertans to enjoy the holidays
with
loved ones in a safe way alberta's
one-time exemption to the christmas
gathering limit starts wednesday and
goes until december 28th
a person living alone can attend one
holiday get-together in another
household
and a household may have up to two
single people as
guests if they have children under 18
they can attend as well
alberta's daily infection numbers have
dropped in recent days
but the number of covet patients being
treated in hospital
is at an all-time high i'd be very
careful
on relaxation of rules especially during
this very precarious time it's the
christmas
season it's the holiday season we know
people are going to be getting together
despite what public health measures
might say and suggest and we really
should be doing everything we can to
keep those numbers down
alberta's recent surge in cases can be
traced back to thanksgiving gatherings
the premier says that can't happen again
the question is will easing restrictions
open the door for more people to break
the rules
there is a risk that some individuals
will go too far
and take this as carte blanche to visit
lots of others
and that would be a bad thing
realistically however those are probably
the individuals who wouldn't have
listened to the rules in the first place
the added risks aren't lost on let's
either so he's been isolating ahead of
the gathering just in case
grateful for even a brief opportunity to
share
some christmas cheer heather yorex west
global news
calgary the federal government is
extending a travel restriction on
passengers from the united kingdom
the original 72-hour ban on all
commercial and passenger flights was set
to expire today
we will extend this temporary suspension
of passion
passenger flights from the uk to canada
for another
two weeks until january sixth
so we can prevent this new variant of
covet 19
from spreading in canada canada is one
of several countries to ban
travel from the uk because of the new
strain late last night france agreed to
reopen its borders to french citizens
residents and truck drivers
the agreement requires travelers to have
proof of a negative covet 19 test before
they can cross the english channel
as crystal gomez explains thousands of
truck drivers are now waiting
to be tested
facing a fourth night stranded in their
vehicles with no end in sight
transport truck drivers are lashing out
an emergency kova 19 testing program is
underway as a part of a deal to reopen
the border between britain
and france it's been an enormous
operation not something that could be
done
instantaneously and it's one of the
reasons why we continue to appeal
to people to stay away from kent and
stay away from the ports in particular
thousands of trucks are caught up in the
virus related gridlock which began
sunday night france is requiring proof
haulers don't have the virus drivers
must sit and wait in their vehicles
until a member of the military or the
national health service
comes by to test them any information
the people need to be patient if they
have information no information maybe
i don't know they get worried infection
rates are
surging in the uk cases are up 57
percent from last week
and hospitalizations are nearing those
seen in april
the health secretary announced more
communities will be locked down
come boxing day but that's not all
a new strain has been found we've
detected two cases of another
new variant of coronavirus here in the
uk
both are cases both are contacts of
cases who have traveled from south
africa over the past few weeks
so the the new variant in the uk which
we've identified
is very different to the variant in
south africa it's got different
mutations
both of them look like they're more
transmissible with another more
infectious strain there are fears case
numbers will rise
even higher anyone who recently visited
south africa or has been around someone
who has
is being told to isolate immediately
crystal gomencing global news
london late tonight the british
transport minister announced he's
temporarily suspending flights from
south
africa starting at 9 am tomorrow british
and irish citizens and permanent
residents coming from south africa
will be allowed in but must self-isolate
for 10 days
no visitors from south africa will be
allowed to enter england
500 families that lost loved ones to
kova 19 in italy have filed a civil
lawsuit against regional and national
authorities
seeking more than 150 million dollars in
damages
the suit alleges the government failed
to update a national pandemic plan
and that failure contributed to
thousands of preventable deaths
this was the scene at rome's largest
train station today
last minute travelers rushing to leave
the capitol
on the eve of a nationwide lockdown over
christmas and new year's
italy has the highest death toll in
europe nearly 70
000 people have died since the beginning
of the pandemic
96 cases are now being linked to a coven
19 outbreak at big white ski resort in
kelowna bc
the health authority for the region says
the outbreak is linked to group housing
and social gatherings health officials
are reminding skiers and snowboarders to
stick to their local slopes
and abide by the provincial advisory
against non-essential travel
an outbreak at a federal prison in
saskatchewan has now grown to more than
130 confirmed cases
the saskatchewan penitentiary detected
its first case of cova 19 on december
12th
in less than two weeks that spread to at
least 123 inmates and 14
staff the canadian red cross is now on
site to help
how the virus got into the prison has
not yet been determined
tonight the canadian armed forces has a
new boss vice admiral art macdonald
commander of the royal canadian navy
since 2016
is the new chief of defense he replaces
general jonathan vance who announced his
retirement last summer
mcdonald was considered the leading
candidate he will now oversee the
rollout of the new covet 19
vaccines the outgoing u.s president is
fired up coming up the enormous spending
bill donald trump thinks is disgraceful
plus why the incoming commander-in-chief
joe biden has to start from scratch
with twitter
u.s president donald trump is
threatening to torpedo a massive coven
19 relief package that has recently been
passed by congress
current federal funding is due to expire
on monday if trump doesn't sign the bill
into law
his last-minute objections are setting
up a showdown within the republican
party
and could risk a federal government
shutdown by early next week
jennifer johnson reports it's taken
forever appearing on camera for the
first time in 10 days
u.s president donald trump lashed out at
congress over its just passed
coronavirus aid package
part of a 5500 page spending bill
the president calls a disgrace it's
called the coveted relief bill
but it has almost nothing to do with
covert this bill contains
85.5 million dollars for assistance to
cambodia 134 million dollars to burma
1.3 billion dollars for egypt but just
600
in aid for most americans i am asking
congress to amend this bill and increase
the
ridiculously low six hundred dollars
to two thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars
for a couple both democrats and
republicans bickered for months over a
second stimulus bill
even delaying their holiday break to
pass this one the bill is so massive
few if any lawmakers actually read it
republicans repeatedly blocked attempts
to give struggling americans more money
we do not have an unlimited checking
account the president's threat to
possibly veto the bill came just hours
after his own white house aides praised
the package
adding he would support it the president
has indicated his intent to sign the
bill
for a few reasons because this is going
to take care of american families with
stimulus checks
house speaker nancy pelosi says she's
ready to introduce a new bill this week
but she'll need the senate on board
to get people money they desperately
need i need to buy me some food
i don't have anything to buy some food
right now i'm running out of food stumps
if there's no agreement and the
president doesn't sign this bill
unemployment benefits for over 10
million americans
run out the day after christmas jennifer
johnson
global news washington trump is leaving
office but not without handing out
presidential pardons he's issued almost
30 pardons and commutations
they include his former campaign manager
paul manafort
charles kushner the father of trump's
son-in-law
john boltby and peter atkinson were also
pardoned
they were both convicted in a fraud
scheme involving lord conrad black
and two people convicted in the mueller
russia investigation
former campaign aide george papadopoulos
and lawyer alex
van der zwan both pleaded guilty to
lying to the fbi
twitter has decided to wipe millions of
followers from the official white house
accounts
when president trump leaves office next
month in 2016 trump of prolific tweeter
was automatically given barack obama's
existing followers
when his administration handed over the
twitter handles for the white house
which each had about 13 million
followers at the time
joe biden will be forced to start from
scratch twitter says followers will be
notified
and given a choice still ahead the crime
behind bars
and the prison guards facing charges
you're watching global national
more than a year after an indigenous man
was killed while in custody
charges have been laid jonathan hanukk
was in a prison in newfoundland and
labrador when he died
tonight a group of correctional officers
and prison guards is facing a range of
charges
ross lord reports the details of what
happened in this saint john's prison
more than a year ago are unclear
but what is known is disturbing inmate
jonathan hanouk
an indigenous man from labrador was
killed he was awaiting trial in the 2016
killing of an elderly woman
hanukkah had a big disadvantage in life
from the day he was born
he was suffering from fetal alcohol
spectrum disorder
he had a very difficult time with that
and our institutions here in
newfoundland had no
idea how to work with him and assist him
those charged in his death
are the same people whose job it is to
provide protection
police say they've laid charges against
10 correctional officers
their identities have not been released
three officers are charged with
manslaughter
one with the additional charge of
failure to provide the necessaries of
life
seven other prison guards are charged
with criminal negligence causing death
a police statement says the accused have
been released from custody
they're scheduled to appear in court in
february a lawyer for hanukk's family
questions why people charged with such
serious crimes
did not face a bail hearing something he
suggests is automatic for indigenous
suspects
and others the difference is that they
are correctional officers
and department of justice employees
that's the difference that's the
circumstance
that's the favoritism buckingham notes
chinook is the third inmate to die in
her majesty's penitentiary in the past
three years
he's calling for a public inquiry into
correctional policies
leadership and training for dealing with
mentally ill inmates
the province's justice minister has
issued a statement saying
we have and will continue to review
policies and procedures in adult
corrections
to ensure we meet best practices from
across the country
the statement sidesteps questions about
favoritism
and does not answer another question
whether the accused are still working at
the penitentiary
now that they've been charged in the
killing of someone in their custody
ross lord global news
up next sending hope a bc couple's
christmas wish for two canadians
held in china
christmas is all about being with loved
ones and it'll be tough this year for
most of us
but spare a thought for michael kovrick
and michael spavor the two canadians
detained in china
who are about to spend their third
christmas alone behind bars
a bc couple who were held for two years
in china
say even the smallest act of kindness
can make a world of difference
abigail beeman explains life in chinese
jail for kevin and julia garrett meant
interrogation
missed meals lights on 24 hours a day
your heads are you know yeah into the
aisle so there's people walking right
past your head
all night it's very very difficult
but through the excruciating ordeal
christmas was a fleeting moment of good
they did this beautiful act of kindness
a makeshift dinner was allowed one year
with their son the other with each other
then it just went back to the normal or
or worse than normal
and so i really feel for the two
michaels they'll be thinking of course a
family of christmas is past
and wanting the same thing again but
they won't be able to have it so
i'm praying and hoping that they at
least the government will allow them to
have a call or something with their
family julia was behind bars for six
months then on house arrest in china
kevin was imprisoned for 775 days
michael kovrig and michael spavor will
soon reach that milestone
they're now facing their third christmas
behind bars
the garretts see the two cases as
similar they were expats in china for 30
years near the north korean border
they were picked up by chinese state
security in 2014
after canada detained chinese citizen su
bin in vancouver
wanted for extradition by the u.s much
like mangwon joe
except the garretts point out the stakes
are higher with a huawei executive vip
the government at the beginning had
indicated to our family
that nothing ever resolves within two
years the garretts encourage everyone to
advocate for kovrig and spavor and join
in the christmas card writing campaign
to chinese embassies
it doesn't matter if they ever see the
card they hear that the cards are there
stacked up piled up and they think okay
people care they're still behind the
scenes fighting that
to me is kind of helped me get through
all those
long lonely moments they'll hear about
the cards
say the garretts from consular visits
supposed to happen once a month coverg
and spavor didn't have them for months
during the pandemic
but have had three in the past three
months those 30 minutes were life-giving
because i got messages from julia from
my family from our kids
they also at some point later on let us
we have photos of my family
eventually the garrett's had a happy
ending kevin was put on a plane home
with little warning
and the family was reunited at the
vancouver airport a resolution they
believe possible for the two canadians
too their family waiting for them inside
the door
and that door will open and they will
just walk through and there will be this
amazing
reunion hug that will it changed our
lives they will never
forget that joyful moment global affairs
won't say whether canada's ambassador
has told the two men about all the
christmas cards
nor whether china has made any guarantee
that the visits will continue
a spokesperson will only say canada
works tirelessly
for meaningful and ongoing access
abigail beeman global news
ottawa and that is global national for
this wednesday night
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
port elgin ontario we would love to see
your corner of this country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you